let's say you meet someone new are women
now saying to you Hey listen Nick you're
cute you're a great guy great provider
blah blah blah blah but Jesus Christ
you're too much of a player you got too
many women you're banging and having
babies with and don't worry are women
starting to tell you no I will not be
with you I'm not out there like that I'm
not dating I'm not I'm really trying to
focus on myself and my children so I
wouldn't even know like my my bandwidth
doesn't even allow me to kind of be in
that space But Nick the only people you
date are your wives you know the women
that you have well you know what I want
the women who have your babies you've
now closed it off to those six women and
even they don't want nothing to do with
me really
is that true like have you said to some
of them listen let's why should we stop
being romantic just because we had to
get in trouble with them every single
day I mean I think it's really it sounds
wild but my main focus is either my
children or work and it kind of it's a
it's a healthy balance and I stopped
like projecting what what I'm what I'm
doing or you know that was 1.1 therapist
told me I should be celibate that didn't
work I had like more kids after that
like it was so I was like
working on myself Nick because of your
sexual prowess and you are a legendary
coxman how many days can you go without
having sex seriously have you ever
denied yourself yes I told you I tried
to be celibate how long did it last
night nine months nine months one time
no masturbation
no masturbation because I still I mean
that's when you're trying to you can't
release that's the whole thing but isn't
that poisonous to your body to hold in
your your old semen and not get it out
and exercise your prostate I'm being
serious I'm asking I I don't think so
I mean chubby like where you guys a long
time ago I don't know because I was very
I was I was younger then too so right uh
yeah so you know you wake up and it's
you had attention type of thing but uh
it's one no you know nocturnal emissions
no wet dreams yeah oh no you know it's
funny during that time it's funny
because I think I was filming a movie
like people were saying I was sleep
[__] like
people would see me put I'd be like
gyrus
rubbing up against some dreams
all right